we've scraped together every vague
prediction plot hint and educated guess
available about the Game of Thrones
prequel in an attempt to get a clearer
picture of what to expect when the
highly anticipated series eventually
makes its way onto television screens
here's what we know
shortly after HBO greenlit the pilot
author george RR martin posted on his
blog that if he got a vote he called the
prequel series the long night martin is
referencing a time of great darkness
that occurred during the Age of Heroes
in which the White Walkers invaded
Westeros they were opposed by the
children of the forest and the first men
with the Nights Watch ultimately driving
them back north during the battle for
the dawn then bran the Builder raised
the magic wall to protect the people of
Westeros against future invasions
however the game of thrones prequel
series is shooting under the working
title Blood Moon while this working
title might be a red herring it may
still hold a few clues in the books
there is a legend that says the long
night began as a result of the blood
betrayal an event in which the brother
of the empress killed his sister and
took her throne he called himself the
bloodstone Emperor and his reign of
terror included torture necromancy
cannibalism and the worship of a black
stone that fell from the sky calling the
prequel project Blood Moon might be a
clue that the Blood Emperor and his
black stone may wind up playing a
pivotal role in the events leading up to
the battle for the dawn in the official
summary for Blood Moon HBO has said that
the show will take place thousands of
years before the events of Game of
Thrones beginning toward the end of the
Age of Heroes & journeying through the
events that led to Westeros is quote
darkest hour
Martin throughout the figure of 10,000
years on his website with the caveat
that it may actually be only half that
whether blood moon takes place five or
ten thousand years before the start of
Game of Thrones we can expect this
version of Westeros to look very
different from the one we've come to
know central Holdings like Winterfell
and the red keep
won't be constructed and the massive
magical wall that divides the north from
the wildlings lands won't have been
built yet the Starks have manned the
wall for thousands of
[Music]
you are a stone considering how far in
the past this series is thought to take
place don't expect to see any familiar
faces pop up on screen while the cast of
Blood Moon may still be populated with
Starks Lannister's and Bolton's they
won't be the ones we've come to know
love and hate over the eight seasons of
Game of Thrones the single exception to
this could be the night king whose
creation we caught glimpses of in Game
of Thrones and who is thought to be
thousands of years old
HBO has promised that the prequel will
reveal the true origin of the White
Walkers which means we may finally learn
who he was before he became an immortal
ice being for all its strengths Game of
Thrones was never known for its diverse
casting or racial sensitivity while
there were some regions like Dorne and
Essos populated by characters of color
the people who resided in them were
never the focal point of the show
however the casting for Blood Moon seems
to indicate that this prequel may
finally take some steps to
course-correct on this issue for actors
of color Naomi a key Sheila Adam Yvonne
o Jeremiah and Marcus Rodriguez have
already been cast as series regulars
since the Westeros we've seen before has
been largely filled with light-skinned
characters this may be an indication
that the new series could spend time in
some previously unexplored lands perhaps
we'll finally get to see esos through
the eyes of the people who are actually
born and raised there or learn about new
lands as well Poldark actor Josh White
House has been cast as the male lead of
the game of Thrones prequel and many
fans are speculating that he'll play a
member of House Stark while there's
plenty of Starks throughout Westeros
history White House will probably be
playing bran the Builder the legendary
founder of House Stark who is
responsible for the construction of
Winterfell after driving the White
Walkers out of Westeros and back into
far north the original bran stark worked
alongside Giants and the children of the
forest to construct the magical wall
that we saw so much of in Game of
Thrones if Martin's claims about the
premise of the show are to be believed
it's hard to imagine a cinematic version
of the long night that doesn't include
bran the Builder combined with HBO's
promise that this prequel will focus on
the Starks of legend it seems like a
no-brainer that one of its main
characters would be
most famous stark of all HBO's official
synopsis for Blood Moon ends with the
cryptic phrase it's not the story we
think we know that's an intriguing claim
even if you only consider the history
revealed over the course of the show but
gets downright perplexing when you take
all of Martin's novels and supplemental
materials into account while Game of
Thrones touched a little bit on the
creation of the White Walkers and the
history of Westeros the show has never
been particularly concerned with the
events of the past keeping its eyes
fixed firmly in the present but when
taken in conjunction with the books and
supplemental texts there are a few
corners of the thrones universe that
haven't already been thoroughly explored
whether you're a casual viewer of the
show or a devoted scholar of the books
prepare for the revelations of the
prequel series to completely upend some
of the histories and stories we've
always believed to be true it's possible
that a character that history recorded
as heroic is actually more of a villain
or that certain events happen
differently than what we've always
pictured Naomi Watts leads the ensemble
cast of Blood Moon and according to HBO
she'll play a charismatic socialite
hiding a dark secret this doesn't do
much to narrow the playing field Game of
Thrones has never had any shortage of
manipulative nobles
however Watts blonde hair and fair
complexion have prompted some early
speculation that she may belong to one
of the two great houses of Westeros
known for their light locks the
Targaryen or the Lannisters the problem
with Watson's character being a
Targaryen is that the dragon riding
family didn't even arrive in Westeros
until a few hundred years before the
start of Game of Thrones that places
them in Valyria during the time that the
prequel will take place while it's
possible that some of the series could
be set in Valyria it seems unlikely that
it will be centered around a lead
character who never even sets foot in
Westeros House Lannister on the other
hand was founded in Westeros during the
Age of Heroes
after LAN the clever tricked house cast
early into giving up their holding of
Casterly Rock
who were your ancestors the ones who
made your family rich fancy legend silk
they were cutthroats that's how all the
Great Houses died it isn't it the timing
works out perfectly for Watts to be
playing one of these early Lannisters
a contemporary of brand the Builder and
while we're used to seeing House
Lannister and House Stark constantly at
war with each other we may finally get
to see them as allies one of the most
common criticisms leveled against Game
of Thrones was its treatment of its
female characters a failing that was
frequently attributed to how few women
have been involved in prominent creative
roles behind the scenes only three women
have ever been credited as writers for
Game of Thrones and only one woman has
directed an episode that all adds up to
only 9 out of 73 episodes with a woman
in a major creative role however if the
creative team behind Blood Moon is any
indication don't be surprised if this
spinoff is much more female centric in
its storytelling not only is nearly half
of the announced cast women but Blood
Moon is helmed by star describe Jane
Goldman her impressive resume includes
writing credits for x-men first class
Kingsman and kick-ass which shows that
she's no stranger to sweeping fantasy
intense action and large ensemble casts
the show has also tapped executive
producer SJ Clarkson to direct the pilot
episode her previous work includes
several shows with predominantly female
cast like orange is the new black and
Jessica Jones the mysterious forest
dwellers who assisted bran Stark in Game
of Thrones will likely get a lot more
screen time in the prequel series in the
main show the children were relegated to
enigmatic side characters who appeared
out of nowhere in season four and then
were seemingly wiped out by season six
but toward the end of the Age of Heroes
the children played a much more
prominent role in Westeros as history
the children of the forest are
inextricable from the tales of bran the
Builder the battle for the dawn and the
construction of the wall they created
the White Walkers and then ultimately
joined forces with the Giants and the
first men to defeat them given their
importance to the time period that the
show will be set during it's highly
probable that one or more of the
announced cast for the series will
portray one of the children of the
forest that means that we're about to
learn a whole lot more about this
secretive race one of the most notorious
figures in Westerosi history is the hero
Azure a high who helped save the world
from a great darkness while wielding his
flaming sword Lightbringer while it is
not made explicitly clear in the books
whether azor Ahai was the
same figure as the last hero who lived
during the long night and helped defeat
the white walkers there's also nothing
to say that it wasn't him
including azor Ahai would give viewers
many of the things we've come to expect
from Game of Thrones tragic love stories
reluctant heroes thrilling battles and a
touch of magic it would also be a way to
include a character familiar to the
audience without needing to bring back
any of the Thrones cast while viewers
and readers have never actually met
Ozora hi he's been the subject of
rampant speculation for years in the
ancient books it's written that a
warrior will draw a burning sword from
the fire
and that sword shall be Lightbringer
seeing him appear on screen would not
only provide the prequel with a rich
character to explore but would excite
fans hungry for more information about
this mysterious hero in an interview at
The Hollywood Reporter shortly before
the final season of Game of Thrones
aired Martyn warned that the prequel
series would be very different from the
Westeros fans had grown accustomed to
seeing it's different it's definitely
very different it's set thousands of
years in the past you're looking at a
whole different era of Westeros no
dragons no Iron Throne no King's Landing
this is hardly surprising given the time
period in which the prequel is set five
to ten thousand years before Game of
Thrones King's Landing hadn't been
constructed and Aegon Targaryen hadn't
yet been born to build a thrown out of
the blades of his vanquished enemies
further while dragons surely existed
somewhere in the world
the Targaryen wouldn't bring the winged
creatures from Valyria to Westeros for
thousands of years still despite the
immense differences between the prequel
and the familiar world of Game of
Thrones Martin is still hopeful that
fans will enjoy it we'll update you as
we hear more about the upcoming prequel
series check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]